what they've been doing a lot of drug
dating a lot of violence all
gang-related
you get stabbings you get acid attacks
and things like that Scott and Dan who
we can't identify our part of Essex
police's operation Raptor unit dealing
with gang related crimes the area's
biggest gang is C 17 and now nine of
them have been served with civil court
injunctions banning them from three
areas within the town several the gang
members are too young for us to legally
identify but these are four of those
served with the banning orders as we're
traveling we get news that one of them
is in the town center where is it this
was filmed this Thursday the day before
the injunction was being served
Billy Montero who's hanging out here in
a betting shop won't be able to come
here from now on you can call you go
call tomorrow because he's been
identified by police as a member of c-17
c-17 has only come on to the police
radar in the last 18 months and their
arrival has been accompanied with
unprecedented levels of violence in the
town such as acid attacks and stabbings
police have recovered knives and guns
along with plenty of illegal drugs
Ontario denies having any association
with the gang and is appealing against
the injunction do you know these other
people these these three others people
OC some things
you don't know them they feel you don't
know they say can't see you knew so you
don't know any of these people well how
is it how's it looking at those areas
that you're gonna be banned from how's
that going to impact on your life you
can't bone me from here you're not God
firm this is a good learn you can't burn
knowing from God London you know good
evidence to ban you because they think
that you're selling drugs they don't
have no evidence do I look like criminal
to you well your name no names on here
I'm gonna put a smile i don't categorize
a criminal by looks it's by what they do
okay look at you do you look like
criminal depends what I've done this is
a relatively new innovation by Essex
police first used by Merseyside Police
and the idea is to make life difficult
for these gangs restrict their use of
mobile phones stop them from accessing
the areas where they're used to selling
their drugs where they can't be put
behind bars the police are trying to
disrupt their criminal activities this
is the c-17 drill music video there will
be banned from making those to police
say they incite violence they won't be
allowed to wear hoodies or interact with
each other on social media police
suspect sexual exploitation is a problem
too we know these gangs are sexually
exploiting young girls in particular
some of the injunction one of the
conditions of the injunction will
prohibit them be able to hang around
associate with people under the age of
girls under the age of 16 years old it's
just one of the one of the measures that
we've got obviously to make that
difficult for them it could be argued
this is watered-down policing the
suspects feel victimized without facing
proper prosecution but nor are the gangs
locked up they could just move on but
Essex Police and the council argues this
is one way of having an instant impact
on what is becoming a highly visible
problem and it will help local people
reclaim their town centre
Jason Farrell Sky News